i've not blown up a balloon in years
scientists know the universe is
expanding like a balloon getting bigger
and bigger but what's causing this
expansion
and will it continue forever this is the
show that asks scientists the big
questions
in the time it takes to travel up and
down 45 floors
[Music]
hey tara hi i hear that you're going to
expand my mind with some information
about the expanding universe
do you think my mind can take it i hope
so can it expand as much as the universe
no okay let's learn
let's set the lift right first you're
scared of lifts
a little bit well this is a great place
for you to be
okay well let's go so the universe is
expanding what is that about
when we looked at galaxies in the early
20th century we realized that they were
moving away from us and the further they
were
they were moving faster so the universe
is expanding what
is that expansion what's happening there
is that will matter being created
no the space between mata is expanding
but
only on the larger scale so if you
imagine some dough with raisins in put
in the oven and heat it up
the dough expands and so all the raisins
are moving away from each other because
the space between them is expanding
so the raisins are planets and the dough
is just empty space they're not planets
they're groups of galaxies
our solar system is joined together
because of gravity
and is that gravity lessening no so
gravity actually holds our solar system
together and our galaxy
and our group of galaxies it's the space
between them that is expanding
and we're halfway oh wow that was quick
yeah that was really quick
okay where were we so groups of galaxies
are moving
why are they moving what's causing this
we think it's a property of space itself
the vacuum of space has a kind of weird
energy that we call dark energy we think
it makes up 70
of the universe and it's what's causing
the universe to expand
and actually accelerate so is that dark
energy filling those spaces or is it
just causing that
it seems to be part of the nature of
space itself
it means that ultimately we're going to
have a really sad lonely death as the
groups of galaxies get further apart
the universe will kind of become cold
and lonely for each of them
um and so that's kind of our inevitable
end we'll die a really sad
death that's really terrifying and not
at all
where i thought this was going to go
right but the good thing for humans
is that the sun is halfway through its
life and in about another four billion
years
it will have expanded to be a giant star
and it will have boiled the oceans and
burnt up everything on earth so we won't
be around for the sad lonely death well
you've given me much to think about
uh with a cold frozen universe
contrasted to a boiling hot earth
that just kills us all that's right that
will happen first
wonderful i don't think you know what
good news means
so we know the universe is expanding but
the big thing is that it's also
accelerating and i will admit i stole a
little bit of tara's time
outside of the elevator because i really
wanted to know more about
how we know this how we measure it and i
found out about a little thing called
red shift
so basically what this is it's kind of
like measuring the doppler effect with
sound right
so you know you hear an ambulance coming
towards you and it gets higher pitched
then lower and it goes
the same thing happens with light so as
things move further away from us
and we're looking at them the frequency
gets lower and it shifts towards red
and because of this we can also see that
it's moving
faster and faster and that's really
exciting to take a look at
now will the universe keep expanding
indefinitely
probably however we will not be around
to see it
so you know doesn't really matter yes it
does that is all from me and
elevator pitch i'll see you next time
hey thanks for watching
if you want to see our elevator pitch
about what happened before the big bang
then you can see that here and if you
want to see more videos like this then
don't forget to hit subscribe
see ya
[Music]
you